so yeah obviously there's uh if you
don't know what chris chan is or the law
behind chris chen it's a very uh
strange tale of the internet um and one
that i don't feel qualified to talk
about i don't think any of us are
qualified
um
how would you
explain what you do to somebody who
doesn't understand anything about
christian or the internet essentially
okay well i talk in depth about
christian and if you don't know
christian is
a certain person who has received a lot
of attention over the years from various
uh online forums and online groups
for his and then later her unusual
actions
and um
that's a very brief introduction a very
simplified introduction there
yeah also has been bullied a lot yeah um
so yeah um
i guess you could say he's um
he's kind of like the forerunner of of
uh several online online groups uh
several online um i guess um
i don't know what
yeah
it's so difficult to like
describe like what he's all about right
you kind of have to go chronologically
year by year to like really get the full
story honestly yeah so
this is all going on because i had not
heard of chris chan until like i think a
few months ago kind of introduced me to
one of your videos
and i was because he couldn't believe
that i hadn't heard of chris chan as
someone who had been on the internet he
was just like
how have you never heard of christian
god's building youtube since which year
now 2000 20 2007. so
basically the start of youtube yeah i
found it
you know how dare you be on this how
dare you be on this website and not know
anything about christianity because like
i knew of things associated with chris
um you know which we'll obviously get
into later in the video but like i when
i heard the name chris chan like
obviously you know knowing because i'm
japanese right so
something changed yeah yeah like oh it's
just like a character or like something
like that and then when i realized that
chris chan was an actual person yeah i
was like oh okay now this completely
changes things so so the reason why this
episode came about my gino is here today
is that uh i've been watching gino's
series now gino does um
well
a kind of a mountain task of documenting
everything and i think what i've said
we're on 59 right now so you have made
uh
roughly around 30 to 50 minute video 50
minute videos how many hours of content
have you made do you even know of course
many people have calculated already it's
over 40 hours i've been over the hours
so this is a 40 hour documentary um you
know michael jordan is eating his hot
hour right now yeah you know the last
dance
you know
40 hours of content and it is just this
very fascinating look into and a side of
the internet essentially it's like a
really interesting just like case study
isn't it just like a person on the
internet and and i think i it's just so
there's nothing like it on the internet
and to have just such material like the
the sheer scale of it is
really daunting and trying to convince
someone to start watching because the
way i train people into uh christian
this whole thing is not because i i
don't particularly care about what
happens but it is almost like a tv show
at this point which we can also get
about later whether that's ethical or
not and you know what not but you know i
get my friends into the documentary i'm
like please watch this it's insane like
when you like introduced us to gino's
documentary at your place that one time
and i saw that there was like 45
episodes at the time i think i was like
oh is this what it feels like to like
try and get someone into one piece no no
i was about to say the exact same thing
this like i saw i saw the episode it was
really interesting and i looked at the
rest of the episodes and just the sheer
length i'm just like oh oh no yeah it's
like i know
i know like because like
just from watching episode one i was
like oh this is so interesting i want to
watch more but just like the sheer
amount just made me kind of fall back a
little bit yeah oh i think i started
watching your series around episode
9 or 10.
um and that's when i started watching
basically whenever you uploaded them
and uh yeah it's been one of those
things where the longer it gets the
harder it is to convince people to start
yeah i think what happened the evening i
showed these guys uh the the series is
that we had like been drinking a bit
yeah and we were like what should we
watch and i was like i know the exact
thing to watch at like midnight let me
let me put it on yeah we finished
watching all the super monkey ball speed
runs and we were like what else what
else can top that chris and connor was
like watch this
so we started watching it um
i don't even know how to begin talking
about this topic because it is so
difficult to explain if the viewers
don't know anything and i imagine the
viewers don't know much um how would you
describe
chris to someone who has no idea who
chris is okay christian is an autistic
individual who
who through the process of bad parenting
and
their own afflictions um caused
themselves to
both become um
uh a subject of bullying online and also
in turn um
they they did not learn
to avoid the trolls
on the internet and by by uh addressing
them all the time only brought them into
into a bigger bigger mess it is just a
case study of what not to do on the
internet yeah almost every single aspect
seems like for me from an outsider
because i think out of the three of us i
know the least about this topic and it
just seems from what i can garner it's
kind of like the perfect storm of
someone who is very susceptible
susceptible to
what people say about them on the
internet and being trolled and just kind
of the worst patrol as possible egging
them on yeah and you just see the result
from that yeah
and uh that's
i mean it's it it says a lot when you
can make 40 hours of content and you're
not even up to date yet are you with the
full story not even close yeah i think
the there was obviously people might
know a lot about the recent news that
happened
um as uh chris chan or uh christine uh
um how do i even say this this year i'm
like afraid to like say it out loud uh
had you know a lot of people like their
mother um unfortunately chris
i'm trying my best to say this without
getting demonetized a lot of people like
their mom but i think chris christie
particularly likes
another level yeah
but the reason why it was so it was
covered in like a lot of mainstream
outlets because it was so despicable
it's like you know chris uh chris
christine had a
sexual intercourse uh with their mother
who uh i believe has dementia is that
correct possibly possibly okay i don't
know but when you see it's very old
right right very clips it's very
concerning
or i think around 80 now yeah and you
know it's obviously uh incest is illegal
and uh
the fact that
it is just insane yeah it is and quite
frankly it's it feels like uh
the worst timeline to be on um it felt
like you know
we can get into it later
what happened after but
how how do you you know when you start
to
introduce the topic of uh christine how
how do you talk about it to people who
have like no idea who want to know about
it
in a sense that okay you've given the
basics of
who who chris was back then and you know
how it all started but
how do you describe the documentary that
you make
uh it's a it's a deep dive into into a
certain
individual that um i guess for for the
most part chris was mostly known for for
the videos on youtube for a very long
time but then i started exploring their
uh quickie which is their their own
dedicated
wiki based on like everything they do
yeah and i've found so much amazing
information and interactions and content
which um gets ignored a lot on youtube
so i i decided to compile as much as i
could as much interesting stuff as i
could into video form to make it more
digestible on youtube and so you just
read all this stuff you're like this is
so interesting i want to repackage it in
a way that is more accessible right yeah
wow